hello everyone and welcome to round one
of yesterday's uh super bits chess
classic it's wesley silver's shakira
mamadarov and if you guys remember
mamamoo won last year's event uh and
it's already uh very interesting that in
round one uh we get a a decisive game in
classical time format and also this is
the only game from round one that did
not uh end in a draw as you'll see after
we check out the game uh so without
further ado let's check it out wesley
has the white pieces and we're gonna
have a very very nice um line of the
nimso indian defense uh not an exotic
one as you guys are used to we've been
having a lot of rapid and blitz games uh
lately this is classical chess so of
course the lines must also be uh
classical worthy so here we have d4 by
wesley knight to f6 c4 e6 knight to c3
and of course the bishop to b4 the nimso
indian defense is on the board uh e3 uh
we have castles by mamadarav and now
bishop to d3 emma there are strikes in
the center with the d5
c captures e captures and now knight to
the e2 is by far the most popular here
wesley goes for a3 first he challenges
the bishop asking are you maybe
interested in capturing the knight here
but black doesn't really gain anything
by capturing it in this line so we just
bring it back bishop to d6 makes sense
to keep the bishop fair uh queen to c2
developing the queen putting pressure on
the h7 pawn at a6 and now only now
knight g to e2 we have rook to e8 uh and
wesley castles we have b6 by mamedyarov
uh b for now grabbing more space on the
queen side knight b to d7 and knight to
f4 and the position has been reached
before even um
this year in the uh feeding grand prix
that was played in belgrade it was
reached in the game between uh
rapport and vidit uh and in that game uh
bishop to b7 was played by vedic rapport
was able to win that game even though
bishop to b7 is the
absolute top move recommended by the
engine uh but here mamijarov plays a
different move he plays bishop captures
on f4 and it is now as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game uh so
let's see how wesley goes about this of
course you have to capture you are down
a piece so e captures an f4 and now you
have a double def pawn but you have very
nice control over the e5 square if you
can uh somehow utilize this to your
advantage so here c5 of course we want
to
get rid of this backwards pawn so we
want to trade it here c5 uh d cat person
c5b captures in the now rook to d1
putting the rook on the same uh file as
the queen uh bishop to b7 and now knight
to a4 now putting more pressure on that
c5 pawn so here you have to react to
this c4 by mama yarov attacking the
bishop and the bishop to f5 now we have
a5 uh challenging the b4 pawn
and here we have bishop to e3 uh here ma
wesley just continues developing a
capture sun b for a captures and now
queen to e7 developing the queen uh rook
ate the b1 uh preparing to push the past
b pawn and the g6 now challenging the
bishop and while you might bring the
bishop back here wesley just trades
bishop for night bishop captures on d7
knight captures and now goes knight to
c3 so here uh now that the position
calmed down a little bit you can see
that wesley
uh has this very nice pass b pawn
whereas mamidarov has two connected pass
pawns the c pawn and the d pawn so who
will be able to push their uh pawns
faster knight to f6 uh now adding a
defender to the d5 pawn as wesley was
threatening to just pick it up
and now bishop the d4 and here this is a
very unpleasant situation for mahmoud
this bishop is just a a monster piece
you can see that the dark square bishop
is much much better than the light
square dish up here the light square
bishop is locked in by by its own pawn
on d5 and it's not really controlling
all that much all that many squares uh
you might be able to re-maneuver it
somewhere but
until you're able to push this pawn to
d4 and open up this diagonal uh it's
never going to be as useful as wesley's
dark square bishop but plus uh it's uh
bishops of opposite colors so uh if it's
going to be an attacking game it will be
as if mamidarov is down a piece of
course you guys know this but it's
always nice to
mention it uh so the dark squares are
incredibly weak if you can you know get
your queen all the way to h6 there might
even be some checkmating ideas all in
all it's uh much easier to play this for
for wesley and uh well the the the one
thing mamadara has going for him are the
two connected past pawns which are now
blockaded and you cannot start pushing
them so here knight to h5 and also just
there there's just the thread of bishop
captures knight and then you can just
pick up the d5 pawn so there's even that
if uh wesley ever wants to get rid of
the
the bishop probably not uh you would not
trade this positional advantage for one
pawn but if he can calculate that it's
winning then why not so knight to h5
going after the f4 pawn queen to d2
wesley defends it have f6 now
and ponte h3 so it's important to give
your king a little bit of a breeding
room here uh the queen and rook are
doubled up on the e file if uh you know
something terrible happens you might
even get checkmated we give up the queen
rook delivers checkmate uh you never
know so h3 always a good idea we have
knights to g7 now re-maneuvering the
knights to f5 uh and bishop to c5 now
challenging the queen here queen to f7
and knight to b5 now winning the d6
square so of course if the knight lands
then that's just game over it's going to
be a game-winning fork so knight to f5
mahmoud defends the d6 square and here
wesley plays knight back to d4
interestingly if you play g4 which is
something
you know every one of us would play in
in a blitz game or or you know maybe in
a rapid game uh it's uh just a dead lost
because now you've allowed the d4 and
that's the power of freeing the uh the
bishop it doesn't matter what white
plays just queen d5 and you're getting
checkmated there there's no avoiding
this for example f3 queen captures okay
your queen is now guarding some uh
squares here but there's rook to a2 just
beautiful beautiful stuff queen captures
we're going to play queen to h1 check
king wherever it doesn't really matter
and queen to g2 will be checkmate so you
really have to be careful uh not to
allow black to execute this d4 move so
here knight back to d4 queen back to d7
and now rook to e1 offering a trade of
rooks with king f7 and now wesley trades
a pair of rooks rook captures we have
rook captures and now rook to a1 winning
the a file for himself hoping to get
that rook all the way to a7 but of
course mamadyarov doesn't allow this
wesley declines the trade plays rookie
one and mommy repeats rook to e8
so wesley not interested in a repetition
he decides to trade here rook captures
queen captures and now finally knight
captures on f5 g captures on f5 uh and
now uh wesley was also successful in
doubling mamiyarov's f pawn here
but it's now uh just uh opposite colored
uh bishops game and it's gonna be very
very hard to push for any advantage but
we know what we simply cannot allow
black to do we can't allow black to play
d for black we will play d4 even if it
means giving up a pawn just to open up
this diagonal and create some counter
play so here just bishop to d4 let's
keep that bishop boxed in
our bishop is just much better than
black's light square bishop so here we
have bishop to c6
and f3 now trying to improve the
position as much as possible before
doing some radical changes to the
structures we have h5 and queen to f2
now we have queen to f8 going after the
b4 pawn not just queen to b2 guarding
the pawn also putting pressure on that
um on that f6 pawn so you have to defend
it and while midarov could just defend
it with queen to d6 he decides to keep
it active he plays queen to b8 he goes
after the f4 pawn and now interestingly
wesley doesn't grab the pawn uh because
uh well it's it's weird but probably
after bishop captures queen captures and
let's say bishop g7 it's not all that
easy to uh to play this with uh
with with black and
there's just not enough time to to open
up the the position to make the light
square bishop useful so while it would
be uh very very interesting uh wesley
decides against this he plays queen to
d2 first now just uh keeps an eye on the
b two point b for pawn now comes king g6
mamadou brings his king to safety queen
e3 now now wesley is offering the pawn
but here if you capture the pawn then
just queen e6 and now you cannot uh
keep an eye on the f6 pawn and under
bishop so now you are just dead lost so
after this king to f7 was played now
bishop to c3 now we guard the pawn
bishop to d7 and king to h2 we have
queen to d6 and now king to g3 wesley
going for a nice little king march here
on the king side
preparing something uh very very cool as
you'll see king g6 we have kink the h
for even now look at this pawn structure
the
uh the white king is completely safe
there uh we have bishop to b5 not just
queen to d4 uh keeping the the pressure
on the position so black cannot leave
the defense of the f6 pawn bishop to d7
we have queen to d2 now bishop back to
c6 and now bishop to d4 we have bishop
to d7 g3 now bishop to e8 and queen to
b2 again putting pressure on the b pawn
preparing to push
on the f pawn and preparing to push the
b pawn so queen to c6 keeping an eye on
the b5 square now comes queen to a3 now
the white queen will uh get a lot more
active if you can if you can
activate it this way so queen to a4
mamijaro offers a queen trade now queen
back to e3 hoping to get to that e6
square but of course queen to d7 and it
seems that there's no way for white to
make any sort of a breakthrough here
but there is one so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this beautiful
idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh spotting
that black simply cannot keep defending
the two weaknesses and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
pawn to b5 so congratulations to
everyone who spotted this yes the
weaknesses are the e6 square and the b5
square and the black queen cannot keep
an eye on both of those uh so here
mamijaro just played queen captures on
b5 and he also resigned to the game here
because it's a forced checkmate in seven
for wesley uh we will show it of course
queen to e6 we just go after the pawn
you can see how the king is also an
attacking piece now queen to c6 we offer
a queen trade plus defend the f6 pawn
but now queen g8 check king h6 and now
the incredible g4 that's why it was
important to have the king on h4 to make
this attack work uh and there's simply
no defense against g5 g5 captures
captures will be checkmate and even if
you trade everything captures captures
and
after captures and captures
again there's no defense against g5 this
will be checkmate whatever black plays
doesn't really matter g5 and that's it
captures captures is checkmate and
another thing after this b5 idea even if
you don't capture the pawn uh then
you're just allowing it to advance and
again uh the black queen will not be
able to keep an eye on the e6 square and
on the b7 square and the light square
bishop is completely boxed in not just
now it's completely boxed in for pretty
much the the entire game uh so you can
see how how dangerous it can beat uh
fianchetto your your light square bishop
with your pawn on d5 and c4 so while c4
was kind of mandatory uh
for you to play in this game it uh
really just made this bishop a terrible
terrible piece uh and of course like i
said if you play queen to e6 oh sorry
not queen to e6 if you play something
like after this um
b5 move if you play something like uh
well it's hard hard to even find the
move here for uh black there's uh
nothing like you play queen to f7 we can
just keep advancing the pawn b6 and
still i mean you will not be able to
defend this you feel like bishop to c6
now we go queen to a3 we go after queen
to a7 there's just no stopping this pawn
you will have to uh
you know
it's it's just impossible to prevent it
the queen now has access to the a7
square to the d6 square where you can
again pressure the f6 square so the
position is just uh two too overwhelming
but mommy wants none of this after queen
captures and b5 he just played it and he
resigned the game and that's it wesley
wins the uh their first round game and
also he's the only player to win the
game uh in round one uh these uh are the
uh are the results of round one i know
you guys were very much looking forward
to seeing caruana versus furuja as
alireza
did not pretty much uh play any uh any
chess for for the past five months after
reaching that 2800 rating uh also
interestingly alireza is the only uh
current uh 2800 player in this uh event
uh as you know as you guys know magnus
ding and dalirez are the only uh uh
three uh 2800 players in the world but
here yeah you can see all the games
ended in the draw wesley defeated mommy
tarot and also if you guys are
interested maybe as some additional info
this uh this is the uh current uh
classical rating uh so you can see that
the cars and ding and firoja are uh uh
above 2800 and then in the top ten you
have karwana rapport nipponishi wesley
anishigiri and hikaru nakamura breaks
into the top ten and then you have uh in
the top
from 11 to 20 mahmud of dominguez perez
rajab of anand duda vashir lagrav uh
karjakin agriculture and topalov still
in the top 20. so uh just a little bit
of extra info if you guys were
interested uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it you can see how
the nimzo indian never disappoints in in
terms of um
well just how strong it is and how
entertaining it is uh i would like to
thank michael colbert ash refined joshua
hadley queen c and bonifate berto for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions uh and the
coverage of this uh wonderful event as
we it's been a while since we had a nice
classical event uh so yeah i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day